pulse you have an interesting theory
about people's fear or creativity yeah
and and and doctoring up shots and then
adding all sorts of expensive equipment
because you think that maybe they're
afraid of their own lack of creativity
or imagination yeah tell us about that
my greatest my greatest insecurity as a
filmmaker is my own talent creativity
calls for town it calls for a lot of
work you know there's like that ten
percent talent ninety percent swear
something that's that later but
creativity making a really good film let
alone a great film calls for talent
creativity originality that to me is the
most difficult aspect and the most
important aspect of filmmaking and
because it is the most challenging and
most difficult I believe a lot of
filmmakers at the beginning stages I'm
not necessarily talking about jump
really well-established legends but
folks in my realm I believe that the
temptation is probably on a deep some
subconscious whatever level the
temptation is to run from the creativity
and write in expensive flashy
entertaining cool witty whatever
elements into the film and producing or
trying to produce flashy wow factor type
stuff such as an a-lister or whatever
having a marginal star in your movie
because that ultimately I think on that
subconscious level people are trying to
distract the viewer from the court which
is creativity which is originality which
is good content it's kind of like a
person who's just all beautiful flashy
on the outside
inside there's just a void they're ugly
and empty on the inside you know so I
think that's a great mistake first and
foremost audience is no better you know
unless it's just a spectacular film on a
production level and people don't even
care about the trite story but they're
clearly not going for the story they're
going for the explosions and stuff but
no one in my realm can do that yet so I
think that's a tremendous mistake and I
think a lot of filmmakers need to take a
personal inventory be honest with
themselves and say why am I writing all
these stunts in my film why am I writing
all this stuff that I probably don't
even have access to rather why don't I
focus on the craft why don't I focus on
the creativity why don't I challenge
myself can I make a good film not
necessarily great this have to be great
but can I make a good film again going
back to my example in my mom's basement
can I make a good film in you know one
or two locations that have access to
that's the challenge and this is the
thing I say time and time again with
friends were arguing debating fighting
the absolute most important thing in
filmmaking as a writer director the
absolute most important thing is craft
or you could call it directorial
execution and that costs nothing you can
demonstrate craft directorial execution
with an iphone camera in a one shot one
shot on your iPhone a one-shot fill one
minute posted on YouTube it didn't cost
you anything you could demonstrate that
it costs you nothing but in that one
shot without iphone with two actors in
your mom's basement
ouch how do you make compelling how do
you make it interesting so that people
want to stay through that whole minute
what are you doing that is the art
that's the art and that's your burden as
a filmmaker that's your burden and
that's what you need to demonstrate that
you can do that and that's what's going
to separate you from the rest so where
do you learn to make those little
nondescript moments compelling so that
you're not relying on CGI exactly to
California and all that crane shots
things I'm man where someone going for
that for that knowledge well there's
definitely something to be said about
gaining knowledge being educated so
there's definitely a role in going to q
and A's listening to commentaries on
like criterion or whatever reading books
there's amazing books like again mark
Stoller ops no budget school you know
like just being in LA I have to say
that's one of the upsides of be in la
there's a stuff going on all over the
place there's something to say that
about that but ultimately where do you
learn where do you get up gather that
that talent that skill set by doing it
that's the only way and that's why I did
seven films in seven weeks last summer
because I had just finished my feature
film it was in post-production I'm like
sit around doing nothing I'm like how is
this filmmaking watching people color
correct my film now I like that tent
better it's not filmmaking so I said
what can I do I envy the painter who
just puts up the canvas you know or the
poet you know I envy that they sketch
you know all great artists all great
painters you see their sketches you
could buy a book of just their sketches
you know like van Gogh and Monet know
that they just did haystacks you know
how can I do that as a filmmaker so I
came up with the idea of I'm gonna make
one short film a week for seven
two weeks and I did it and I learned a
lot are they great Matt or note i didn't
even submit them to film the books i
don't care because there are sketches so
I like to think I'm a better filmmaker
now after doing that and I might
actually do it again this fall so by
doing those seven goals in seven weeks
you learned when a look translated kind
of spoke a thousand words and in these
very subtle things that you didn't need
a lot of resources to be able to have
people emotionally invested what did you
see once you walked away from those
seven films that you realize that I
don't need all these you know well big
shiny yeah i mean i was already
convinced of that going into it but
making the in terms of what we're
talking about with the seven films you
know i i'm just going to be really
honest i don't think any one of my films
is really exceptional I don't quite
frankly has a lot to do with making it
in a week I don't think a lot of
filmmakers even the great masters would
be able to make an exceptional film in a
week but and this is very important I'd
say an almost all of them if not all
objectively speaking there is at least
one thing that really worked well like
in my fifth film there's a little
monologue that one of the characters
says that I just think I nailed as a
writer so my point is making those seven
films really affirmed to me first and
foremost that hey maybe I do have a
little bit of talent and secondly you
know just an actor standing in a kitchen
you could have granted she's a good
actor okay
but you can have something really cool
happen you know it didn't need to be
Halle Berry didn't need to be you know
in the location that costs ten thousand
dollars a day I didn't have a
multimillion-dollar crew whatever but
it's pretty darn good and a lot of
people still talk about that one
you